so a 30 year old woman from the bay area
recently went on a hike which led to the
fires over in i forgot which county but
so she's at 30 yeah norcal she is a 30
year old former yoga teacher who was in
a hike she ran out of water was very
thirsty she found a puddle on the floor
and thought oh it's water i'm gonna
drink it shortly upon taking a few sips
she realizes that it's bare urine and so
she tries to filter it out with the tea
bag that doesn't work so she then tries
to boil it in order to make it drinkable
she couldn't get it done she drinks it
anyways and it starts a fire just on the
[ __ ] hike that's still going on right
now
was she like missing or how long she got
out there she was out like an hour about
i think a few days ago started drinking
beer piss yeah she probably didn't know
it was therapist i don't know she does
she said that it was bear piss and then
she tried to boil it out so it really
drinkable yes like a heavy like beer
piss a lot of piss but it wasn't and you
just like woke up at hibernation just
pans
just that dark
hibernation
probably tastes like a warm ale yeah get
let me see a bear pissing and did it let
me see a bear did it have uh was it did
it piss in a bowl i mean what what it
was on the floor she said it was a
puddle of piss
i don't know if i'm buying she knows
it's a bear piss
could have been a fat ass moose or an
elk like how do you know it's a bear
yeah right a bear specifically it's
right there it's him taking part there
he goes it's not even that hard yeah now
i'll piss harm that's scratching the
back too
yeah that's not bad at all i love it
tiny pee pee too for a big animal yeah
well
well that ain't [ __ ] dude
it's definitely not bear piss no it's
natural
sounds like she might be full of [ __ ]
what ha so if you create the forest
fires and all that [ __ ] how's that
effect like obviously
you don't
like if you did unintentionally right
like you didn't mean to do it
unintentionally what happened you still
pay the [ __ ] you pay the fines because
there was the the fire can't be cheap
dude burning hundreds of acres they're
like well here's your bill how much we
burned 500 000 acres of forest
run through the numbers it's just the
timber lowest oh here we go 177 million
all right
like good news about that makes 70 grand
a year are you related jeff bezos no
okay so i got bad news really bad news
yeah about the people who started the
wildfire from the baby baby the baby
gender announcement yeah they have to
pay all of that and i think they could
have faced jail time trying to buy a
tree go see how much one oak tree called
it
millions of them down yeah but the thing
is like how's that work so let's see him
and his wife make let's say a hundred
grand between the two of them what do
you do you're you're not you're just
working for the rest of your life you're
basically a slave to this part yeah i
don't think i think there's a reasonable
there's a difference they have to well
but also the government's like dude
they're never yeah it was
a trillion dollars
you might as well say you you're
trillion dollars i think what happens is
at the end of the day people go
sorry
you know you can barely get started out
you know how sometimes you really yeah
well you know you really like this you
go
i'm sorry or the government just you
know what you're doing you're really
good
what the [ __ ] did you do
sorry i think the government just
garners your wages like that's where
they discipline they probably take out
for your check all the time you have to
take this as an answer
yeah i mean even if you gave them a
million they got a million dollars to
the government whoops does it say how
much those the her fines were
it says on there the fine that she might
have to pay but she did end up because
of that fire
144 houses were burned down [ __ ] so like
she's always pay for it what does she do
getting sued by those homeowners as well
i mean
you guys think
i would put in catastrophic no what
happens yeah
what happens why yeah what happens if
you start a force
what is
[Laughter]
ah five years in prison and find so much
it's 250 000 that's probably minimum
chin pull up the original article again
mm-hmm because i'm pretty sure it
happens to accidentally start a force
yeah see where it says she's a
self-described shaman so she's full of
[ __ ] yeah off the bat yeah so there was
no bear piss
self-described shaman yoga teacher and
dive master
all just yeah
[ __ ] dude
you're in her face she doesn't look like
she's real
she she well she looks shell shocked
she's like yeah yeah um
that's i [ __ ] up um
that's a lot yeah yeah she's gotta go to
the squid game yeah by the way
yeah by the way that's what happens
you're a contestant in squid kid
and you could win a lot or get shot in
the [ __ ] she must have been a smart
girl cal tech oh yeah she must have been
smart sure but just you know sometimes
not great with forest fire it doesn't
mean you're good at fire
no sometimes you just you make a fire
and you're like it's dry here
you have the government i don't know
what you do you know i mean you just you
know you go you can't start a fire in
the woods it's not a good idea
in august yes if you're in british
columbia and it rains all the time the
rain forest you're going to be fine
sure